tonight is the fifth night of Hanukkah
we have a long treasured tradition here
on our show which celebrates the
festival of lights that's right you know
what I'm talking about it's time once
again for our annual lighting of the
human centipede menorah
[Applause]
yeah well
well to help me light the Human
Centipede menorah this year it's my
pleasure to introduce a representative
of the great Jewish faith her sisters a
rabbi the incredibly talented Sarah
Silverman
[Applause]
Coenen as you know Hanukkah is a
glorious tradition where we remember
when the Jews were enslaved in Egypt and
sewn together asked to mouth by a
deranged scientist you make it sound so
magical oh it is and to celebrate I'm
gonna be feeding the front guys some
greasy potato latkes with hot coffee so
you know we feed the front face to
remind the ass faces of our suffering
incredible
[Applause]
okay it sounds like the human menorah is
not thrilled about this no I know but
it's okay it's tradition
are you eating and now I think it's time
to light the human centipede menorah
would you help me please
[Applause]
to everybody
I love you baby